i can ask you about the big bang
uh so we talked about the space and time
are really big
but then and we humans give a lot of
meaning to the word space
and time in our in our like daily lives
but then can we talk about this moment
of beginning
and how we're supposed to think about it
that at the moment the big bang
everything was uh
what like infinitely small and then it
just
blew up we have to be careful here
because there's a uh
there's a common misconception that
the big that the big bang is like the
explosion of a bomb in empty space that
that
uh fills up the surrounding place it is
space
it is yeah as we as we understand it
it's the fact it's the the fact or the
hypothesis but
well supported up to a point that uh
that everywhere in the whole universe
early in the history uh matter came
together into a very hot
very dense if you run it backwards in
time
matter comes together into a very hot
very dense and yet very homogeneous
uh plasma of all the different kinds of
elementary particles and quarks and
antiquarks and gluons and photons
electrons and anti-electrons everything
you know all of that stuff
like really hot really really
really hot we're talking about uh way
way hotter than the surface of the sun
uh you know well in fact if you
take the equations as we as they come
the the prediction is that the
temperature just goes to infinity but
then the equations
uh break down we don't you know we don't
really
with their various the equations become
infinity equals infinity so they don't
feel
that it's called a singularity we don't
really know
uh this is running the equations
backwards so you can't really get a
sensible
idea of what happened before the big
bang we don't you know so
we need different equations to address
the very earliest moments
but so things were hotter and denser we
don't
really know why things started out that
way
we do we have a lot of evidence that
they did start out that way
but since most of the uh you know we
don't get to visit there
and do controlled experiments most most
of the
most of the record is is very very
processed and uh
we have to we have to use uh very
uh subtle techniques and powerful
instruments to
to get information that has survived
getting closer and closer to the big
bang get closer and closer to
the the beginning of things and
what's revealed there is that uh
as i said there what there undoubtedly
was a period when everything
in the universe that we have been able
to look at
and understand and that's consistent
with everything
is uh um
the was in a condition where it was much
much hotter
and much much denser uh but still
obeying the laws of physics as we know
them today
and and then you start with that so all
the matter is in equilibrium
uh and then with small quantum
fluctuations and run it forward
and then it produces encoura at least in
broad strokes
the universe we see around us today do
you think we'll ever be able to
with the tools of physics with the way
sciences
or the way the human mind is we'll ever
be able to get
to the moment of the big bang in our
understanding
or even the moment before the big bang
can we understand what happened before
the big bang
i'm i'm optimistic both that we'll
be able to measure more
so observe more and that we'll be able
to figure out more
so they're very very tangible prospects
for uh observing the
extremely early universe so much even
much earlier than we can
observe now uh through looking at
gravitational waves
gravitational waves since they interact
so weakly with
ordinary matter uh sort of send an unpr
a minimally processed signal from the
big bang
it's a very weak signal because it's
traveled a long way
and diffused over long spaces but uh
but people are gearing up to try to
detect gravitational waves that could
have come from the early universe
yeah ligo's incredible engineering
project yes the most
sensitive precise yes
devices on earth the fact that humans
can build something like that is uh
truly awe-inspiring from an engineering
perspective right
and but these gravitational waves from
the early universe would probably be
of a much longer wavelength than lyco is
capable of
sensing so there's a beautiful
project that's contemplated
to put lasers in different parts
different locations in the solar system
you know we really really separated by
uh solar system scale differences like
artificial planets or moons
in different places and and see the tiny
motions of those relatives to one
another as a signal of
of radiation from the big bang we can
also maybe
indirectly see the imprint of
gravitational waves from the early
universe on
uh the photons the the microwave
background radiation that that
is our present way of of seeing into the
earliest universe but those
those photons interact much more
strongly with matter they're much more
strongly processed so they don't give us
directly
such an unprocessed view of the early
universe
of the very early universe but if
gravitational waves leave some imprint
on that
as they move through we could detect
that too and people are trying our
you know as we speak working very hard
towards uh
towards that goal it's so exciting to
think about a sensor the size of a solar
system
like uh that would be a fantastic i mean
that would be a pinnacle
artifact of human endeavor to me it
would be
such uh such an inspiring thing
that just we want to know
and we go to these extraordinary lengths
of making gigantic things that are also
very sophisticated because what you're
trying to do
you you have to understand how they move
you have to understand
the properties of light that that are
being used the interference between
light and
you have to be able to make the light
with lasers and understand the quantum
theory and
get the timing exactly right you know
it's an extraordinary endeavor
involving all kinds of knowledge from
the very strong very small to the very
large
and all in the service of uh
curiosity and built on a grand scale so
yeah yeah so it might be proud to be a
human if we
if we did that i love that you're
inspired both by by the power of theory
and the power of experiments so this is
the both both i think are
exceptionally impressive that the human
mind can come up with theories
that give us a peek into how the
universe works but also
construct tools that are way bigger than
uh
the the evolutionary origins we came
from right
and by the way you know the fact that we
can design those things and they work
yeah is an extraordinary demonstration
that we really do
understand a lot and then
in some ways and it's our ability to
answer
questions that also leads us to be able
to address more ambitious questions
you